Twitter is dropping all political ads
from the site triggering a new debate
about free speech CEO Jack Dorsey
tweeted yesterday quote while internet
advertising is incredibly powerful and
very effective for commercial
advertisers that power brings
significant risks to politics where it
can be used to influence votes to affect
the lives of millions
Errol Barnett is with us Eero good
morning so why is this move so
significant
well good morning partly because of the
fact that it's the exact opposite of
Facebook's decision last week to
continue selling political ads even if
they contain false information
Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg called it
free expression but here Twitter's Jack
Dorsey argues political influence should
be earned not bought we've made
significant progress recently in
response to growing backlash about
hosting political ads Twitter CEO Jack
Dorsey took an all-encompassing stand
against them a political message earns
reached when people decide to follow an
account or retweet he wrote we believe
this decision should not be compromised
by money but Facebook's decision to not
censor politicians even at the risk of
spreading misinformation face scrutiny
on Capitol Hill last week I think lying
is bad and I think if you were to run an
ad that had a lie that would be bad so
you won't take down lies or you will
take down lies so I think it's just a
pretty simple yes or no in a democracy I
believe that people should be able to
see for themselves what politicians that
they may or may not vote for you won't
take for themselves
Zuckerberg double down on that point in
an earnings called yesterday in a
democracy I don't think it's right for
private companies to censor politicians
or the news Democrats largely praised
Twitter's policy shift while Trump
campaign manager Brad Pascal called it
quote yet another attempt to silence
conservatives Twitter is doing this
because Twitter is a platform that is so
closely aligned with news and politics
Sarah Fisher is a media reporter for
Axios and says the decision is not about
money but sending a message that certain
types of free expression can do more
harm than good so many people were
abusing the system lying in ads they
were very hard to regulate and I think
that it's doing what it things
for its community and Fisher also told
us Twitter feels it must regulate its
own content since there's no federal
oversight and it's not tied to the same
rules and regulations as broadcast
networks like CBS they must allow all
ads regardless of whether they contain
lies Twitter's new policy goes into
effect November 22nd yeah so no ads
Twitter says but of course all the
politicians from all sides are gonna be
on there saying whatever they want to
say right and there will be six billion
dollars expected to be sent on political
ads this election cycle so that
influence will be out there just not on
the Twitter platform
Errol thank you very much and as Errol
just mentioned broadcasters like CBS are
bound by the Federal Communications Act
and generally precluded from rejecting
or changing an ad from a candidate for
president this does not apply to pack
ads and cable networks do not have the
same obligations